Und wie lange dauert das in Schweden?
Ja, Leute, es ist jetzt der wohlfühlte Teil. Entschuldige, lass mich in Ruhe. Und das andere Mal, ich habe mir dieses Jahr eine Smartwatch gekauft und eine der Sachen, die ich tatsächlich relativ häufig damit mache, obwohl die unfassbar allweil in der Öffentlichkeit ist, aber die wirklich gut funktioniert ist, telefonieren. Es ist wirklich das beste Freisprechtelefon, das ich jemals in meiner Hand gehabt habe. Und wenn ja, man telefoniert mit seinem Handgelenk und es ist unfassbar allweil, ich denke mir so, ey, das ist doch geil. Ich hätte jetzt eher Star Trek gesagt, aber ja, im Prinzip.
Da hatten die die Kommunikatoren noch in der Hand und dann später eine Brust zum draufkippen.
Aber Michael Knight hat doch wirklich in seiner Armandur gesprochen.
Aber das ist doch die bekloppteste Haltung. Viel bessere Haltung ist irgendwie, aufs Handinnengelenk zu drehen und einfach die Hand am Ohr zu halten.
Geil, das muss ich mal sagen. Aber da hatte ich tatsächlich auch so einen kurzen Moment, wo ich dachte, ich habe in meinem Handgelenk ein Ding, das ist so groß wie eine Uhr. Und da drin ist alles, inklusive der SIM-Karte, um zu telefonieren. Und ich kann damit meine Mails lesen. Und das fand ich, also ja, das hat bestimmt alles Nachteile. Man kann damit Leute tracken und weiß ja geil was. Aber ich fand das auch geile Science Fiction.
Ich hab da eine Frage zu. Wie ist das denn? Also du hast Freisprechanlage gesagt. Hören dann die Leute neben dir?
Ja, ja, man will das nicht in der Öffentlichkeit machen. Aber sozusagen zu Hause oder im Auto zum Beispiel ist es total super.
Wenn die Leute sich vom Weiten bewundern können.
Was macht der da? Er spricht in seinem Handgelenk. Das ist ein cooler Typ. Nein, ich glaube, das passiert nicht. Nein, aber wie gesagt, da hat für mich technologischer Fortschritt gerade eine Hürde genommen. Weil da hat mich auch Glauben gemacht, Smartphones letztlich eine Brückentechnologie. Man will das nicht auf Dauer mit sich rumschlippen.
Bestimmt, also es wurde ja ganz oft gesagt, sobald es Sprachsteuerung gibt, dann wird das alles obsolet. Nur alle haben ja im Vorfeld auch schon gewarnt, Sprachsteuerung gerade in der Öffentlichkeit ist nicht das, was man unbedingt haben will.
Ja, aber da gibt es ja noch, also zumindest das Science-Fiction-Konzept von Mikrofonen sub vokalisieren, also quasi die, die im Kehlkopf drin sitzen, wo du quasi mit dir selber sprichst tatsächlich. Soweit sind wir noch nicht. Das fand ich übrigens auch eine spannende Entwicklung, die also apropos mit Dingen sprechen, dass ja diese ganzen Alexa-Dinger jetzt so unfassbar steig gegangen sind in dieses Jahr und letztes Jahr so ein bisschen. Da hatte ich auch einen ganz starken Impuls, ich finde das geil, ich möchte gerne zu Hause mit meinem Computer sprechen, mit dem Dinge sagen können, aber ich möchte halt gerne zu Hause. Jetzt fang ich auch schon an, das wieder schlecht zu reden. Dann habt ihr noch was Schönes erlebt vielleicht?
Ja, hab ich. Und das ist wie auch bezeichnenderweise geht es auch um Gesundheit. Ich hatte dieses Jahr das erste Mal so einen größeren Stapel Rechnungen vom Arzt eigentlich einzusenden. Und da gibt es inzwischen, da gibt es eine App. Ich weiß zwar nicht, wie sicher die ist, aber ich habe mich erst mal darüber gefreut, dass ich jetzt einfach so mit meiner Kamera aus der Hüfte geschossen, diese Rechnung von oben fotografieren. Dann haben sie so Entsteuerung, irgendwas Technologie, zeigen die nochmal an, ist das da, was da ungefähr steht, ab dafür. Und dann bekomme ich dann eine Mail zurück und die kümmern sich. Und ich muss wie keine großen Batzen Papier an irgendeine, was ich eh mal wieder vergesse, dann zur Post zu tragen. Und die antworten mir, wie oft zum Kanal, natürlich auch per Mail sagen sie Bescheid, dass ich nachgucken soll. Und kann dann im Internet gucken, ob sie das erstatten oder nicht. Und das war toll. Ich glaube, das ist, wie sich Anwälte gefreut hätten, wenn BEA funktioniert hätte. Hatte ich das Gefühl gehabt. War schön dieses Jahr.
Und das war auch von der Krankenkasse tatsächlich. Oder von dem Drip-Anbieter. War das eine Frage?
Ja, das war von meiner, ich hoffe, das war von meiner Krankenkasse.
Vielleicht weiß auch jetzt jemand anders Bescheid.
Das Geld kam an.
Aber ich habe zwei Dinge, wo ich denke, die kleinen Dinge schätzen. Die erste war tatsächlich, dass sich ein großes deutsches, traditionell eher nicht so richtig innovatives Unternehmen, auch wenn sie mich dafür wahrscheinlich schlagen würden, etwas getan hat, was ich total genossen habe. Ich habe mich seit langem wieder in der Bahn gesessen und konnte da einchecken. Und habe mich hingesetzt und es war okay und niemand hat mich angemauert. Niemand wollte Fahrkarten sehen. Es war einfach alles okay. Und um das Ganze wieder negativ zu machen, die Bahn hatte Verspätung. Ich möchte Kosten rückerstatten und dafür gibt es noch keinen Button. Dafür haben sie den maximal umständlichen postalischen Weg gewählt mit Dreifachstempel und Unterschrift.
Also als ich das das erste Mal testen wollte mit dem Einchecken im ICE, da gab es kein Internet.
Womit wie wieder beim Anfang der Sendung gehts.
Ich finde es aber sehr lustig. Kleine Anekdote muss ich dir erzählen. Ich habe das auch gemacht. Also das ist es klingt ja wirklich total praktisch. Vor allen Dingen, wenn man gerade keinen Bock auf Menschen hat. Man sitzt im Zug, klickt auf sein Smartphone und dann ist quasi die Fahrkarte kontrolliert. Was mir die ersten paar Male passiert ist und dann denkt man, man sitzt so bequem in seinem Sessel, so niemand wird dich ansprechen, niemand wird dich stören. Du bist ja eingecheckt. Was erst mal mal passiert ist, so, ah, Sie haben ja eingecheckt, nicht wahr?
Sozusagen das zweite Erlebnis und da wollte ich ja meinen Ohren nicht trauen. Vielleicht habe ich das auch wirklich nur halluciniert, war, als ich eine Bundestagsdebatte hörte und Frau Merkel erklärte dem Bundestagsplenum, wie agile Entwicklung geht.
Wie was geht?
Agile Softwareentwicklung, also dass man das heute ja nicht mehr mit großem Plan und einem riesen Chart macht, sondern dass man quasi erst mal anfängt und in kleinen Schritten und dann mal guckt und so. Und ich weiß nicht, was ich schlimmer fand, ob die Tatsache, dass sie das zwar gut erklärt hat, aber bei allen wahrscheinlich nur hängen geblieben ist, ja, das ist irgendwie nicht ernst zu nehmen, weil sie ist nämlich wirklich ausgelacht worden, als sie das erzählt hat. Ja, also das Plenum hat wirklich gelacht. Ich weiß nicht aus welchen Fraktionen das kam, aber es wurde gelacht.
Auch dem Neuland?
Nee, aber mich würde tatsächlich mal interessieren, man müsste mal ein Protokoll nachlesen, da wird ja vermerkt, Gelächter aus den Reihen der XY-Fraktion, wer da drin steht. Das habe ich leider noch nicht getan. Und das andere, was ich ja befürchte, wenn man so was hört, denkt man nämlich, ja, endlich, verstanden. Aber das Problem ist natürlich, so eine Agilität verschont einen natürlich nicht davor, irgendwie Security und so mitzudenken. Und ich fürchte nämlich...
Ich habe doch in dieser Sendung schon gelernt, was man macht ist, man macht die App, dann wirft man die auf den Markt, dann hat man ganz, ganz, ganz viele Nutzer und Sicherheit macht man später oder gar nicht, wenn es billiger ist, den Dsgvo-Verstoß zu zahlen.
Weißt du, was das andere große Thema ist, was jetzt in der Presse nicht vorkam?
Das eine mal lohnt sich. Also geht nach dem, wie diese Sendung als Podcast rauskommt, geht auf chaosradio.ccc.de, guckt euch diese Stelle noch mal und seht dann immer verzweifelnd, weil ich voll gegen dem, was ich gerade gesagt habe.
Wir hatten da irgendwie so Steuerskandale, die dann so ein bisschen unter den Tisch geworfen wurden, weil irgendwie eine Nerz oder so wieder was Grundrechte einschränken und großes Ablenkungsmanöver gebracht hat. Aber das ist genau der Effekt von agiler Programmierung, einmal auf Gesetzgebung im Steuerbereich angewendet. Die haben sich Steuergesetze ausgedacht, die einfach so komplex sind, dass Leute, die mit einem großen Stil mit Aktien handeln, hinkommen können und sagen, liebes Finanzamt hier, wir haben gerade mal die führenden Steuerexperten eingekauft, die werden jetzt nicht mehr für euch arbeiten, sondern für uns. Und die haben uns alle beschieden, das euch Steuern wieder wegzunehmen, die wir nie bezahlt haben, alles juristisch legal ist. Das ist eigentlich auch ein Hack. Das ist einfach im schlechtesten Sinne ein Hack. Aber sie haben dort einmal...
Also du verurteilst das Ergebnis, aber handwerklich war es ganz schon clever?
Ich weiß nicht, ob das handwerklich so clever war, einfach mit viel Geld viel Personal einzukaufen, die da Kritik üben könnten, auch fundiert. Ist dann auch sehr ein Plumper-Hack. Aber sie haben dort handwerkliche Schwächen in dieser durch doch sehr hemmsärmigen Implementierung dieser Steuergesetzgebung ausgenutzt, um sich da zu bereichern und Geld zurückzufordern, was sie nie an Steuern bezahlt haben. Und das passiert, wenn du dann wie so Agile Development machst, dann immer irgendwie irgendwas...
Du musst jetzt mal erklären, was das heißt.
Ja, Agile Development sind einfach mehrere Konzepte, die darunter zusammengefasst werden, aber grundsätzlich sagen wir machen nicht am Anfang einen Riesenplan, wie die Software werden soll, sondern wir machen mehrere Milestones, also mehrere größere Meilensteine der Entwicklung. Hört sich jetzt wie pathetischer an, als es ist. Und gucken dann immer, wir gehen dann dahin, gucken, was der Kunde dazu sagt, geben ihm ein neues Preisupdate, was es dann wohl am Ende kostet, kann er sich dann entscheiden, dass er irgendwie... Wir haben jetzt gemerkt, dieses Feature brauchste vielleicht noch, das da brauchste nicht. Kann er sich dann währenddessen entscheiden und die Entwickler machen das so mit und der Kunde hat eine bessere Kontrolle darüber, was ihm dahin entwickelt wird.
Aber das klingt doch geil.
Das klingt geil, wenn du Software programmierst. Das klingt nicht geil, wenn du Gesetze machst.
Weil du dann nicht mehr durchblickst.
Weil du erstens nicht mehr durchblickst. Zweitens ist dann, wenn der Alpha-Version von deiner Software plötzlich zerbröselt, dann ist der Schaden übersichtlich. Wenn du Gesetze schreibst und da von Menschen betroffen sind, dann möchtest du, dass da Erwachsene am Start sind, die sich da irgendwie viel Gedanken darüber machen, alle Schlupflöcher schon von Anfang an mitdenken. Man würde denken, da sitzen dann in den Häusern Juristen, die das irgendwie wasserdicht zuklöppeln, aber nie Finanzjuristen sind, ein eigenes Völkchen da, was die da in Frankfurt sitzen und üblicherweise da sich da hinklüngeln und...
Also, apropos Gesetze, ich möchte noch mal einen Namen sagen, wo ich vermute, dass ihr zumindest so grob eure Richtung tangiert, weil mit Überwachung und Staatstrojanern und sowas Polizeigesetz.
Ja, das ist sowohl negativ als auch positiv. Negativ sind natürlich neun Polizeiaufgabengesetz. Also, noch mal zur Erklärung. Das Polizeirecht ist in Deutschland Ländersache. Das heißt, was die Landespolizei darf, das wird in jedem Bundesland festgelegt. Es gibt natürlich einen Rahmen, aber da gibt es eben Gestaltungsspielraum. Und da hat in diesem Jahr Bayern gesagt, wir brauchen das härteste Polizeigesetz seit 1945. Das haben sie nicht so gesagt, aber es haben dann später Juristen gesagt, die sich dann das Gesetz angeguckt haben. Und die haben das Gesetz dramatisch verschärft, Klauseln reingenommen, wie beispielsweise, dass die Polizei sehr tiefgehende Maßnahmen machen kann, wie beispielsweise jemanden inhaftieren oder die Wohnung durchsuchen oder die Telekommunikation abhören, schon bei Hinweisen auf eine sogenannte drohende Gefahr. Und das Problem an solchen schwammigen Rechtsbegriffen ist, dass das natürlich Auslegungssache ist. Was ist eine drohende Gefahr? Da geht es um Wahrscheinlichkeiten, da geht es um Vermutungen. Und da begibt man sich immer mehr in diesem Bereich des Pre-Crimes. Ja, und darüber hinaus... Pre-Crime, sag ich mal. Also man versucht, schon aktiv zu werden, bevor eine Straftat stattgefunden hat. Und ja, Teil des Gesetzes war auch noch eine Ausweitung der sogenannten Präventivhaft, kann man es nennen. Das bedeutet, man kann Menschen, obwohl sie noch gar keine Straftat begangen haben, einsperren, weil man den Verdacht hat, dass sie zukünftig eine Straftat begeben werden. Das Problem an der Sache ist, normalerweise wird das gemacht, wenn jemand aufgegriffen wird und der ist unzurechnungsfähig betrunken. Dann wird der in die Ausnichtungszelle gebracht. Maximal drei Tage in Berlin, dann kommt man wieder raus. In Bayern kann das leider bis zu unendlich gehen, weil solange man Richter findet, der immer wieder diese Maßnahme verlängert, gibt es da kein gesetzliches Limit mehr nach oben. Das Problem ist ja auch normalerweise, wenn du angeklagt wirst für eine Straftat, dann kriegst du einen Pflichtverteidiger. Du kannst dich juristisch wehren. Aber wie willst du dich denn gegen etwas wehren, was du angeblich in der Zukunft, wie willst du beweisen, dass du angeblich etwas nicht in der Zukunft machen wirst?
Und warum solltest du überhaupt beweisen, dass du etwas nicht gemacht hast?
Ja, es ist vollkommen gaga. Ja, genau.
Aber das war ja nur ein Vorschlag, das ist doch nicht in Kraft, oder?
Doch, in Bayern ist es schon in Kraft. Und in Bayern gibt es schon erste Fälle, bei denen eben, also vorher haben ganz viele Verbände gewarnt. Also das Gesetz brauchen wir nicht, das ist gefährlich. Das gefährdet unsere Freiheit, unsere Bürgerrechte. Und man kann schon sagen, dass ja, so in den ersten Monaten recht schnell klar war, dass die Befürchtungen tatsächlich Realität geworden sind. Die ersten Opfer dieser Maßnahme, also dieser Präventivhaft, waren Geflüchtete. Die von der Polizei inhaftiert worden sind. Und dann hat man länger nichts mehr von denen gehört. Und das haben auch diverse Verbände dann kritisiert.
Ist Bayern noch ein sicheres Herkunftsland?
Bayern ist kein sicherer Ort mehr für Bürgerrechtler. Soweit würde ich tatsächlich gehen, weil du weniger Möglichkeiten hast, dich vor Polizeieingriffen zu schützen. Und die Polizei viel schneller, viel mehr darf. Ohne konkrete Beweise vorzulegen, sondern einfach aufgrund von Wahrscheinlichkeit.
Aber ist das wirklich eine demokratische, juristische Diskussion, die man führt, oder eine politische? Oder hast du konkret gesagt, ich fahre jetzt eigentlich nicht mehr nach Bayern?
Ja, ich bin nach Bayern gefahren. Und das ist das Positive. Zur größten Demo für Bürgerrechte, die es in München seit mehreren Jahrzehnten gegeben hat, wenn nicht sogar überhaupt. Und man muss schon sagen, da hat sich ein riesiges, gewaltiges Bündnis zusammengeschlossen. Mehr als 40.000 Menschen sind gegen dieses Gesetz auf die Straße gegangen. Und ich war da und ich hab mich richtig alt gefühlt. Und das ist ein sehr, sehr gutes Zeichen. Das gibt mir Hoffnung. Ich mein, vor zwei Wochen war ich in Potsdam auf einer Demo gegen das brandenburgische neue Polizeigesetz.
Warte mal, lass mich raten. Die anderen wurden jetzt so, ah geil, was die Bayern da gemacht haben, das machen wir jetzt auch.
Also natürlich hat unser geliebter, als als geliebter Innenminister Horst Seefuhofer auch direkt damals gesagt, ja, das muss ein Musterpolizeigesetz werden. Und das ist ein Wettrüsten zwischen den Bundesländern. Man hat jetzt in einem Bundesland gesehen, was man alles in so ein Gesetz reinschreiben kann. Und ja, die anderen wollen jetzt nachziehen. Auch natürlich, weil sie glauben damit auch, ja, Sicherheit zu demonstrieren. Ob das Sicherheit bringt, ist natürlich eine andere Frage. Und in Niedersachsen gab es auch große Demonstrationen in NRW. Und in Niedersachsen beispielsweise fordert man so eine Art Landestrojaner, so ein Staatstrojaner auf Landesebene. Man will Videoüberwachung im öffentlichen Raum auswerten. In Brandenburg wird Schleierfahnung diskutiert. Taser, ne?
Schleierfahnung musst du, glaube ich, mal erklären kurz.
Ja, es ist eigentlich anlasslose Polizeikontrolle, ne? Also irgendwie, du siehst doof aus, komm mal raus.
Was, ich sehe, Entschuldigung?
Ja, und das ist also das Gute, was man sieht. Also in Bayern ist es ja so, dass die CSU damals noch die absolute Mehrheit hatte und da konnte man wenig ausrichten. Leider, aber man kann schon sagen, dass die Demos zumindest in Niedersachsen und in NRW dazu geführt haben, dass die Landesregierung so von ihrem Extremplan ein bisschen zumindest abgerückt sind. Ja, also die Gesetze sind immer noch furchtbar und schlimm, aber man hat dann zumindest gesagt, so ja, Moment mal, wir werden jetzt beispielsweise den Begriff der drohenden Gefahr so ein bisschen entschärfen, oder dieses Präventiv ein bisschen entschärfen. Oder doch nicht mehrere Monate präventivhaft, sondern nur ein paar Wochen. Das sind natürlich nur Makulaturänderungen.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, ist ja der Verdacht, dass die Forderungen eh so maximal waren, dass sie jetzt da sind, wo sie eigentlich hinwollten?
Ja, das ist die Befürchtung, deshalb müssen wir auch weiter demonstrieren. Beispielsweise am 8. Dezember in Hannover und Düsseldorf. Ganz, ganz viele, ganz viele Millionen, ja. Aber man muss auch sagen, dass das natürlich auch ein bisschen Taktik, glaube ich, von den Landesregierungen ist in diversen Bundesländern. Die wollten eigentlich im Sommer noch die Gesetze verabschieden. Sommer ist natürlich eine Top-Zeit für Demonstrationen. Und die haben das jetzt auf den Winter geschoben. Und umso wichtiger ist es, dass man sich trotz des Wetters, trotz der Temperaturen rausquält, weil die Genugtuung darf man denen nicht geben. Dass ihr Plan aufgeht.
Demonstrationen geht auch nur mit so einem Schal, meinste. Sehr gut. Wir müssen ja noch über den bevorstehenden Chaos-Communication-Congress reden. Wie lange brauchen wir dafür? Äh, beliebig lang. Ich hab ein Thema, das mich persönlich interessiert hat, und was, glaube ich, auch nicht ganz unwichtig ist, was in dem Jahr immer so an mir vorbei geschrammt ist und was jetzt irgendwie nicht, dass nichts explodiert, deswegen hab ich nicht so genau angeguckt. Ich dachte, da musst du doch normal reingucken. Und jetzt sag ich, wo ihr alle gerade hier seid, vielleicht könnt ihr mir das erklären. Da geht's nämlich im Weitesten auch ums Digitale, nämlich ums Digitale Veröffentlichen und einem Namen, der immer wieder auftaucht, Elsevier. Wer oder was ist Elsevier und warum ist das für die Wissenschaft wichtig?
Na, Elsevier ist ein Verlag, in dem normalerweise wissenschaftliche Publikationen veröffentlicht werden. Also der veröffentlicht wissenschaftliche Publikationen. Das sind entweder Fachbücher oder das sind auch so Aufsatzsammlungen. Also wenn man als Forscher ein Thema beackert hat, dann schreibt man üblicherweise hinter ein sogenanntes Paper. Und man muss quasi dieses Paper, damit das irgendwie auch so von der Fachwelt rezipiert, also angenommen und gelesen wird, in einem solchen Verlag wie eben Elsevier. Elsevier? Elsevier? Keine Ahnung. Elsevier. Veröffentlichen. Springer ist der andere. Also nicht Axelspringer, sondern Springer. Wirklich nochmal was anderes. Und Elsevier ist halt aktiv geworden, weil oder nochmal auf die Grundproblematik zu gehen. Die Grundproblematik ist nämlich, man muss diese sogenannten Journals kaufen. Also nicht mal ich selber, aber z.B. jede Bibliothek. Auf der Welt. Auf der Welt. Das ist sehr, sehr teuer.
Moment mal. Jemand veröffentlicht in einer Zeitschrift Dinge und die muss gekauft werden. Das klingt jetzt erstmal nicht so schlimm.
Nicht Zeitschrift mal.
Naja, aber du musst ja auch überlegen, wer schreibt denn die meisten wissenschaftlichen Beiträge? Das sind Professoren, das sind Forscher, die mit unseren Steuergeldern quasi finanziert werden, damit sie Forschung betreiben können. Und meine Annahme als Bürger, als Steuerzahler wäre, dass es frei zugänglich gemacht hat.
Ja, aber das ist auch die Entscheidung. Da könnte man natürlich, aber das sind ja die Professoren schuld. Die könnten es auch einfach auf ihre Internetseite stellen.
Da hast du das große Problem mit dem Peer Review. Es gibt da so ein Konzept in der Wissenschaft, dass du nicht mit jeder steilen Theorie einfach nach draußen gehst und sagst, hier ansteigen gilt alles nicht, sondern es soll ja immer alles kritisch beäugt werden von anderen Koryphäen im Fach. Deswegen veröffentlicht man das in so ein paar Kanälen, die anerkannt sind, wo man davon ausgeht, dass alle anderen das lesen. Dann wird es entweder im Nachhinein oder im Vorfeld von anderen, die in demselben Bereich forschen, kritisch beäugt. Die schicken dann Empfehlungen an die Verlage zurück und sagen, ja, das hat halt schon Fuß, hier und da muss man noch was nachjustieren. Dann wird das erst veröffentlicht, überhaupt erst. Und dann ist dieser Peer-Review-Prozess an der zweiten Phase. Danach gucken dann so alle drauf und dürfen dann noch auch wieder Leserbriefe einschicken, um da fundierte Kritik dran zu üben.
So wie Software auch entwickelt werden soll.
Zusätzlich ist es ja noch so, dass es auch darum geht, um die großen Namen. Das heißt, wenn ich beispielsweise Forscher bin und ich mich irgendwann auf eine Professur bewerbe oder vielleicht Student und auf eine Doktorandestelle, dann ist das leider in der Wissenschaft nicht unbedingt wichtig, wie gut mein Paper war, sondern dass ich in den richtigen Magazinen veröffentlicht habe. Und die nehmen mich natürlich eher, wenn ich mich an deren Regeln halte.
Aber ich verstehe noch nicht, warum. Die verdienen jetzt Geld mit dem Ding, wo ihr sagt, politisch sollte das anders sein. Wenn es in meiner Twitter-Timeline vorbei geraucht ist, da ist so, das sind die großen, bösen Weltuntergang, da ist Wader, der Wissenschafts...
Ja, aber überleg dir das mal. Derjenige, der das Paper schreibt, kriegt nichts dafür. Derjenige, der reviewt, und das sind üblicherweise mindestens drei, kriegen da auch nichts für.
Der muss zuweilen auch bezahlen.
Genau, und letztendlich die einzigen, die da Geld für kriegen, sind die Leute vom Verlag, die auf das Kopierenknöpfchen drücken.
Warte mal, nur weil sich die Wissenschaftler nicht einigen können, wir bauen jetzt hier diese schöne Webseite, da tun wir alle unsere Sachen rauf und peer-reviewen die auch, und dann ist das auch sozusagen ein großer Name, weil wir das beschlossen haben, nur weil die nicht den Arsch hat, so eine Hose haben, verdient sie viel Geld und das ist jetzt irgendwie böse.
Das ist historisch gewachsen zu der Zeit, als es online immer alles noch nicht so richtig ging. Und dann haben sich diese großen Verlage auch noch Modelle ausgedacht, wo sie dachten, ach, schöne Universität, die du da hast, du brauchst da dieses eine ornithologische Magazin, da irgendwie so ein Monatsabo, ja, pass auf, da bezahlst du entweder irgendwie 150.000 Euro im Jahr, oder du bezahlst irgendwie für dieses Abo, wo dann noch viele andere tolle Dinge dabei sind, nur ein bisschen weniger. Und dann haben sie da so Zwangsknebel-Abo, ist da immer jedem einzelnen Institut da noch reingeholfen, dass man dann einfach nicht nur ein einzelnes Magazin abonniert, sondern gleich das gesamte Portfolio. Und es ist dann auch ziemlich schwierig, da rauszukommen. Das heißt, dass jede Fakultät, auch noch von unseren Steuergeldern, wieder für ihre Bibliothek, damit ihre Studenten sich dann dieses ornithologische Naturmagazin angucken konnten, mussten dann irgendwie auch noch solche Stangen Geld daraus tun, die dieses Riesenabo gekostet hat. Das haben sie hinbekommen, weil sie in der Zeit vor dem Internet einfach einen Oligopol aufgebaut haben von so zwei, drei großen Verlagen, die das dann durchgedrückt haben. Und dann musste man das einfach ausliegen haben. Und die haben in der Zeit auch so viele Veröffentlichungen gesammelt, auf die sie dann einmal Verwertungsrechte geltend machen. Das heißt, wenn jetzt Wissenschaftler in dem Feld irgendwie Interesse an einem bestimmten Artikel haben, dann können die sich das nicht einfach irgendwo besorgen, sondern müssen wieder zu Elsevier gehen und sagen, gib mal her, und hier ist viel Geld dafür. Um das lesen zu dürfen. Und wenn du jetzt sagst, wir einigen uns mal auf irgendwas anderes, geht das nicht, weil die Verwertungsrechte da liegen.
Die alten Paper kann man also dann gar nicht mehr.
Man könnte doch jetzt anfangen, 2008 hätte doch das Jahr...
Das tun jetzt Leute und haben dann erst mal angefangen, einen Grundstock aufzubauen an einer Seite, die heißt Zaihab. Hat, ich glaub, ein israelischer Student, jetzt will ich gar nicht lügen, aufgebaut. Und ist dann natürlich gleich in größere Urheberrechtsstreitigkeiten mit...
Er hat keine neuen Artikel reingesteckt, sondern auch alte?
Er hat dann erstens alle möglichen Veröffentlichungen zusammengesammelt, hat Leute da was hochladen lassen, hat dann so kleine Mini-Peer-Review-Logik eingebaut, dass da auch kein Blödsinn drin steht. Und ist natürlich so, hat nicht lange gedauert, aber dann wurde er angegangen, sollte seine Seite runternehmen, dann gab es irgendwie lauter Mirrors.
Ich muss dich mal kurz korrigieren. Es ist eine Dame, die nennt sich Alexandra Elbaikyan. Und die ist Kasachin.
Siehste, hab ich komplett daneben gelegen. Danke schön. Danke Alexandra. Und diese Seite sollte dann runtergenommen werden, und dann gab es plötzlich überall ganz viele Mirrors, nachdem sie dann auch den Inhalt veröffentlicht haben. Und der hat das Elsevier hergegangen und versucht in allen möglichen europäischen Ländern wirklich Filter für alle möglichen Scihub-Mirrors zu erwirken.
Das klingt wie Zensur.
Das ist Zensur. Und weswegen es jetzt wahrscheinlich zuletzt durch deine Twitter-Timeline geschwappt ist, ist, weil einer der größeren ISPs in Schweden, Bahnhof, sich dagegen erst gewehrt hat. Dann haben sie vor Gericht verloren. Jetzt müssen sie blocken. Diese Seiten sind einfach so unfassbar genervt davon, weil so der Schwede an sich...
Hat ja Glasfaser, würde ganz viel runterladen.
Genau, und der... Die haben dann gesagt, na gut, dann müssen wir das umsetzen, haben eine eigene Blogseite stattdessen installiert, blocken aber auch Elsevier. Das heißt, hier...
Und das Gericht.
Das Gericht, das die Entscheidung da durchgeknüppelt hat.
Aber das geht noch weiter und...
Das geht wahrscheinlich weiter. Das ist jetzt wie Pipi aus dem Pool fischen. Geht nicht. Die Wissenschaftler haben Blut geleckt. Jetzt gibt es die ersten Universitäten in Deutschland, die sagen, sag mal, was passiert da gerade? Nee, wir wollen keine Lust mehr. Diese großen Knebelverträge. Jetzt ist Elsevier bei einigen großen Universitäten, die sich zusammengeschlossen haben, gesagt, wir machen jetzt einmal mit geballter Macht des Einkaufs. Sagen wir, wir lassen uns diese Knebelverträge da nicht mehr überhelfen und haben da schon auch noch ein bisschen an der Preisschraube nach unten gelegt.
Genau, und bis man wieder über die Bibliotheken an die entsprechende Publikation rankommt, weil kommt man ja jetzt hier nicht mehr, eine wichtige Forderung geht auf gar keinen Fall auf sciminushub.tv, weil das ist illegal.
Gut, gut, dass wir das wissen. Vielen Dank. Wir hören jetzt ein bisschen Musik. Und von Cronowolf, Third Time's the Chin. Und dann geht's in die letzte halbe Stunde im Chaosradio. Mal gucken, was da noch kaputt gemacht wird. Dankeschön.
Hallo, mein Name ist Jan Böhmermann und ich lese jetzt vertrauensvoll alles vor, was mir die Fritzen auf diesen Zettel geschrieben haben. Also, ich hätte gerne zwei Hompfpamp-Zwirbelzipfel und eine Schlackermuffe mit drei bis zwölfer Flanschgewinde, die aber bitte ungezipfelt. Außerdem spiele ich ganz neben Malgesagt zusammen mit dem Rundfunk Tanzorchester ein krass populistisches Potpourri meiner Greatest Hits live und in Berlin.
Fritz präsentiert Jan Böhmermann und das Rundfunk Tanzorchester Ehrenfeld.
Damit du diese verdr... dem Metropole wenigstens einmal einen Hauch von Hochkultur zieht.
Am 26. schon komplett ausverkauft, aber auch am 27. Januar. Jan Böhmermann und das Rundfunk-Tanzorchester Ehrenfeld live in der Kolumbiale. Jan Böhmermann.
Ein Hauch von Hochkultur. Präsentiert von Fritz.
Hört man, wa? Nach einem halben Jahr im Weltall ist die Sonde Insight am Abend erfolgreich auf dem Mars gelandet. Die US-Weltraumbehörde NASA hat bestätigt, dass sie Funksignale der Sonde empfangen hat, die das bestätigen. Vor allem das gut sechs Minuten lange Landemanöver hatte den Forschern Sorge gemacht. Es gehörte zum schwierigsten Teil der Mission. Ob der Mars-Roboter die Landung komplett überstanden hat, muss sich noch zeigen. An Bord sind auch Forschungsinstrumente aus Deutschland. Mit ihnen soll geklärt werden, wie der Mars genau aufgebaut ist und was sich unter seiner Oberfläche befindet. In Teilen der Ukraine wird übermorgen das Kriegsrecht eingeführt. Das Parlament in Kiev hat am Abend mit klarer Mehrheit zugestimmt, dass die Behörden für einen Monat mehr Rechte bekommen sollen. Präsident Poroschenko erhofft sich davon, das Land besser gegen Russland verteidigen zu können. Die Ukraine wirft Russland vor, in der Nähe der annektierten Halbinsel Krim ukrainische Schiffe beschossen zu haben. Russland beschuldigt die Ukraine dagegen, illegal in russische Gewässer eingedrungen zu sein. In Berlin und Brandenburg haben seit heute die meisten Weihnachtsmärkte geöffnet. Vor allem für die großen und bekannten gelten erhöhte Sicherheitsvorkehrungen. So sind zum Beispiel die Zufahrten am Potsdamer Weihnachtsmarkt durch Transporter versperrt. In Berlin wurde unter anderem der Weihnachtsmarkt an der Gedächtniskirche mit schweren Sperren abgeriegelt. Dort geschah vor zwei Jahren der Terroranschlag mit einem Lastwagen. Union Berlin bleibt als einziges Team der zweiten Fußballliga ungeschlagen im Spitzenspiel beim Hamburger SV holte Union gerade noch so ein 2 zu 2 Unentschieden. Der Ausgleich für Union fiel erst in der letzten Minute vor Schluss. Union steht damit auf Platz 3, der HSV ist erster. Minus 3 bis plus 2 Grad sind's immer noch. Es gibt viele Wolken am Himmel, im Laufe der Nacht lockern die aber im Norden auch noch ein bisschen auf. Ein bisschen kälter kann's noch werden und stellenweise müsst ihr auch mit Glätte rechnen. Der neue Tag startet dann noch neblig trüb. Später gibt's aber auch ein bisschen Sonne, mehr als 3 Grad kriegen wir trotzdem nicht. Und in den nächsten Tagen bleibt es kühl, aber es soll auch längere sonnige Phasen geben. Insgesamt fließt der Verkehr auf den Straßen ganz gut. Es gibt eine Meldung von der A113, dem Zubringer Schönefeld statt auswärts. In Höhe Johannisthaler Chaussee steht ein kaputter Laster auf der rechten Spur. Fahrt da vorsichtig. Und noch zur S-Bahn, das betrifft die S-Bahnlinie 5. Da müsst ihr zwischen Strausberg Nord und Hoppegarten auf Busse umsteigen. Und außerdem fahren auch keine Züge zwischen Ostkreuz und Ostbahnhof. Und die S9, die entfällt, zwischen Treptower Park und Ostbahnhof. Dort, wo es geht, schau ich eine gute Fahrt.
Mehr aktuelle Infos rbb24.de Und wenn ihr diesen Sound mögt oder diesen Sound, dann hört doch mal Hyper-Real Radio Beste Musik mit Mifahin Stange immer freitags ab 20 Uhr und im Radio oder jederzeit auf fritz.de Slash Musik Streams.
Oh mein Gott, 2008 ist gleich vorbei. Und wir müssen jetzt noch den Jahresabschluss schnell hinkriegen. In der letzten halben Stunde im Chaosradio im Blumen. Mein Name ist Markus Richter und zu Gastin, Danimo, Katascha, Peter und Erdgeist, der gerade ganz aufgeregt was auf seinem Computer zeigt. Was machst du da? Uns vorbereiten. Wir gehen nur vorbereitet in die Sendung.
Natürlich.
Also 2018 ist viel passiert, aber egal. Wir haben gerade über Polizeigesetze gesprochen, neue, die eingeführt werden sollen und daraufhin hat Peter angerufen und sagt, das ist ja alles nicht so.
Oder?
Hallo Peter. Du findest, die Polizeigesetze, die neuen, seien zu schlecht dargestellt worden.
Warum? Was heißt zu schlecht dargestellt worden? Es ging zum Beispiel gab es in dem Gespräch deiner Mitsprecherin den Hinweis, da lasse die Polizei jetzt auf einmal, sich auf einmal, wenn du irgendwo besoffen durch die Gegend fällst, dich einfach mal drei Tage wegsperren kannst. Das war ein Punkt. Das stimmt wohl nicht. Ich selber bin ja auch bei der Polizei. Nein, in Bayern nicht, in Berlin.
Wir haben ja über das neue Polizeigesetz in Bayern geredet.
Richtig. Nichtsdestotrotz stellt man sich aber hin und erzählt, dieses Polizeiaufgabengesetz ist ja nur eine Erweiterung zu den aktuellen Gesetzen. Dieses Sicherheits- und Ordnungsgesetz, was es hier in Berlin gibt, das ist das gleiche Gesetz vom Wortlaut her, wie es in Bayern ist. Jetzt bekommen die Bayern ein paar mehr Befugnisse, die prinzipiell gar nicht schlecht sind, finde ich. Weil ich finde, in dem Bericht stellt man die Polizei so hin, als hätten sich alle drauf gefreut, endlich mehr Befugnisse zu bekommen, um irgendwelche armen Menschen einfach ohne Grund ins Gefängnis einsperren zu können.
Aber dem ist einfach nicht so. Ich mag dir glauben, dass du das so siehst, aber wenn wir über neue Gesetze diskutieren, diskutieren wir immer auch über die juristischen Maximalmöglichkeiten. Und dann ist die Frage, erlaubt es das neue bayerische Polizeiaufgabengesetz, Menschen für längere Zeit wegzusperren, ohne dass eine Anklage erhoben wird, ja oder nein?
Ja und nein, weil die Polizei...
Das geht nicht.
Ja, Moment, einsperren tut es tatsächlich, die Polizei darüber befinden tut ein Richter.
Ja, aber das wurde ja genauso gesagt. Es wurde ja gesagt, das geht, wenn man einen Richter findet, der immer wieder dieses Ding unterschreibt. Das ist also richtig.
Ja, also was auf jeden Fall auch nochmal, also wenn ich... Ich glaube, also dein Einwand war richtig, man kann natürlich niemanden wegsperren, weil er irgendwo besoffen aufgegriffen wurde. Was ich sagen wollte ist, dass diese, also das quasi eine Haftmaßnahme...
Wenn er so besoffen ist, dass es für ihn oder für andere eine Gefahr entsteht, kann man ihn natürlich einsperren, muss man ihn auch einsperren.
Ja, aber eben nur für eine gewisse Zeit und ich finde das ist richtig. Ich finde das auch gut, wie das derzeit in Berlin gehandhabt ist, dass es eben da eine ganz klare Begrenzung nach oben gibt. Interessanterweise war es auch so, dass sich in Bayern tatsächlich auch Gewerkschaftler von der Gewerkschaft der Polizei gegen das neue Gesetz ausgesprochen haben, weil sie gesagt haben, wir möchten hier mehr Kontrolle, weil sonst haben wir das Gefühl, wir fürchten, dass da auch das Misstrauen von der Bevölkerung gegen uns steigt, wenn es keine ausreichenden juristischen Kontrollen gegenüber Griffe gibt. Und das finde ich auch einen richtigen Schritt zu sagen. Da gibt es eben großen Nachbesserungsbedarf bei den Kontrollmöglichkeiten, weil klar, wir unterstellen auf gar keinen Fall, dass alle Polizisten das jetzt maximal ausnutzen würden. Das spielt ja auch die Justiz eine Rolle und so weiter. Aber es geht bei Bürgerrechten immer um die maximalen Möglichkeiten und um die Checks and Balances. Also wie ist das, wenn ich als Betroffener im Worst-Case-Szenario wirklich falsch verdächtigt werde? Was sind meine Möglichkeiten, mich zu wehren? Und die sind einfach schlechter geworden durch das neue Polizeigesetz, insbesondere in Bayern. Wie sind die denn schlechter geworden? Na ja, also wie gesagt, wenn du angeklagt wirst, wirklich eine Sache zu machen, dann kannst du dich ja verteidigen. Du kriegst einen Pflichtverteidiger. Wenn du allerdings vorbeugend in Haft genommen wirst, dann kriegst du keinen Pflichtverteidiger. Und das ist schon mal ein immenses Problem für Menschen, die nicht so viel Kohle haben, sich das zu leisten, die vielleicht auch sich nicht mit dem deutschen Recht auskennen. Ich hatte das ja gesagt, dass in Bayern auch die ersten Fälle schon da sind, wo eben Geflüchtete betroffen sind. Die kennen sich mit dem deutschen Rechtssystem vielleicht auch gar nicht so gut aus.
Und er ist recht, wenn das einfach auf Dauer weitergehen kann. So, das geht aus meiner Sicht gar nicht in einem Rechtsstaat. Einfach auf Dauer, ohne weiteres einfach eingesperrt zu sein.
Ja, aber nichtsdestotrotz hört sich das für den Hörer oder für mich so an, als würde jetzt irgendein um die Ecke kommen, irgendeinen von der Straße auflesen und den in den Bunker stecken. Und da versauert der erst mal bis zu, weiß nicht, so lange, wie ihr eben gerade gesagt habt. Und dem ist halt einfach nicht so. Genau, sie hatte doch eben dieses Thema dieser Schleierfahnung angesprochen. Das hörte sich so an, wie, naja, nur weil du jetzt, das wurde ja auch wortwörtlich so gesagt, nur weil du scheiße ausziehst, bist du eingesperrt. Oder wirst du kontrolliert. Natürlich kann ich, natürlich ist es ja, man darf halt eine Sache nicht vergessen. Wenn ich als Polizeibeamter draußen rumlaufe oder draußen rumfahre, habe ich einen gewissen Auftrag. Nämlich einen gewissen Sicherdorf, einen Herbstest, einen Aufrecht zu halten und irgendwelche Straftaten zu verfolgen, auch präventiv. Diese Schleierfahndung, es ist ja nichts anderes. Die Straßenverkehrsordnung gibt es ja auch hier. Ich kann dich doch auch verdachtunabhängig kontrollieren. Du glaubst gar nicht, wie viel verdachtunabhängige Kontrollen wir machen und dabei tatsächlich auch Straftaten feststellen. Aber wie gesagt, ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, ich kenne mich mit diesen Polizeiaufgaben, ich habe das noch nicht im ganzen gelesen. Was mir aber heute ums Mirum in dieser ganzen Sache geht. Dass das einer Meinung nach ein bisschen einseitig hingestellt wird.
Peter, da muss ich an dieser Stelle aber unterbrechen. Wir haben hier auf der einen Seite jemand, der sich ganz ausführlich damit beschäftigt hat, mit diesem Polizeiaufgabengesetz. Und dann haben wir jemand, der sagt, ich habe das gar nicht richtig gelesen. Und wir diskutieren gerade über die juristisch maximalen Dinge, die da rauskommen können. Peter, lass mich bitte ausreden. Und es ging hier sozusagen, ja, wir haben gehört, dass du gesagt hast, das ist nicht richtig dargestellt, dass das alle so machen würden. Das ist doch nicht die Absicht gewesen. Das haben wir ja auch erkannt. Aber in die Tiefe dieses Gesetzes jetzt zu diskutieren, fehlt uns A, die Zeit. Und B, wenn eh nicht alle Seiten ganz genau wissen, was wir von dir reden, ist es ja auch ein bisschen sinnlos, oder?
Ja, stimmt, aber nicht, dass du drückst. Mir geht es einfach darum, dass ihr gewisse Sachen auch ein bisschen anders betont. Weil auch manchmal macht der Ton die Musik und es wird in manches andere Sicht reingesteckt. Das ist ja blöd, weil ich habe das tatsächlich in einem Zusammenhang mitgekriegt. Das hätte ich mal versucht. Weil das, wie es erzählt wurde, stellt jetzt einfach falsch dar. Und darum geht es mir.
Vielleicht wie das in den meisten Fällen tatsächlich passiert. Aber der Punkt ist ja, was passieren könnte und noch rechtlich sauber wäre. Und wenn wir als Bürger plötzlich nicht mehr Rechte haben, frei auf der Straße zu laufen, ohne dass es Beweise gibt, dann hat das Land ein Problem.
Ich sehe das so, dass wer am Ende ein Problem damit hat, dass darüber gesprochen wird, dass ihm gerade ganz viele Rechte eingeräumt werden. Und am Ende meint, aber die brauche ich alle gar nicht. Warum du dich persönlich angesprochen fühlst, wenn du am Ende gar nicht vorhast, diese Rechte zu missbrauchen, das verstehe ich schon nicht. Ich glaube, da kommt irgendwie die Negative. Das Negative kommt dann irgendwie beim Empfänger eher raus. Und die bayerische Polizei versus Berliner Polizei ist, glaube ich, auch noch mal ein ganz anderes Kaliber. Wer schon mal mit anderer Hautfarbe oder bestimmten Merkmalen am Münchner Hauptbahnhof langgelaufen ist und dabei dann geracial proof halt wurde, ich würde...
Erdgas, Erdgas, Erdgas. Also ich glaube schon, dass wenn man sozusagen zur Polizei gehört, in der Sinne dazugehört, dass man diesen Effekt, also das nehme ich schon auch ab. Und ich finde auch gut, dass wir das dargestellt haben, dass es sozusagen in der Diskussion nicht darum ging, zu sagen, alle machen das immer über alle in einem schlimmsten möglichen Ding, sondern dass es hier darum geht, dass dann ein Gesetz verabschiedet wurde, was das theoretisch möglich macht und damit ein Missbrauchspotenzial schafft, was gefährlich ist. Ich glaube, an der Stelle können wir uns dann vielleicht sozusagen auf die Diskussion heute hier einigen. Aber in der Tat spannendes Thema, das sollten wir vielleicht nochmal ausführlicher machen, wird ja wahrscheinlich uns in Berlin auch bald drohen, oder?
Ja, also in Berlin ist das jetzt noch nicht direkt absehbar. Und es ist auch, ja, also hier sind die Mehrheiten einfach auch andere. Hier gibt es keine CSU, das muss man freundlich zu formulieren. Allerdings, also was mir noch mal ganz wichtig ist, ist zu sagen, dass es auch um ein Missbrauchsprotenzial für die Zukunft geht. Denn wenn einmal solche Gesetze eingeführt sind, es passiert es ja ganz selten, dass man sagt, so viel brauchen wir doch nicht, oder wir stürzen das zurecht. Das wird ganz selten gemacht, meistens wird es eher ausgeweitet. Und ich frag mich einfach als besorgter Bürger, wie die politische Situation in 10, 20 Jahren hier in Deutschland aussehen wird. Mit einem, ja, also mit einem Klima, was, finde ich, deutlich nach rechts rückt. Und interessanterweise gab es da auch in München vor ein paar Monaten noch mal eine Demonstration. Da hat sich das Bündnis gegen das Polizeiaufgaben gesetzt, mit dem Bündnis ausgehetzt zusammengetan. Und die haben zusammen eine Demo gemacht und gesagt, so unsere beiden Forderungen sind eigentlich eine Forderung gegen den Rechtsruck und aber auch gegen eine Ausweitung von Befugnissen, die eben auch missbraucht werden können. Wenn Richterposten mal anders besetzt wären, wenn vielleicht auch die Stimmung in der Bevölkerung eine andere ist. Weil ich frag mich immer, wenn Begriffe nicht eindeutig definiert sind, wie beispielsweise drohende Gefahr, potenzieller Gefährder, heute sind sich vielleicht die meisten Polizisten einig, was es ist, vielleicht, wenn es aber nicht so definiert ist, sieht das in 10, 20 Jahren anders aus. Du hast aber trotzdem immer noch diese Begriffe in dem Recht. Das heißt, die Gesetze können irgendwann auch ganz anders verwendet werden als ursprünglich intendiert. Und das ist eben so ein langfristiges Risiko, was diese Gesetze haben.
Okay, Peter, können wir dann auf der Stelle die Diskussion okay halten? Letzter Satz noch von dir. Okay, dann vielen Dank für deinen Anruf auf jeden Fall. Und gute Fahrt noch. Sehr schön, hätte mir das auch geklärt. Vielen Dank. Ja, das ist auch geil. Also nicht nur Jahresrückblick, sondern so Chaosradio-Rückblick. In der letzten halben Stunde rufen die Leute an und bringen sehr interessante Sachen an, über die man dann wieder um zwei Stunden reden könnte. Aber dann ist die Sendung gleich vorbei. Na, vielleicht hätten wir früher drüber reden sollen. So, wie gesagt, das Jahr ist gleich vorbei, die Sendung ist auch gleich vorbei. Und am Ende des Jahres findet was statt?
Der Kongress.
Der was, Kongress?
Der Chaos Communication Kongress.
Der wievielte Chaos Communication Kongress?
Der 35. Chaos Communication Kongress. Und wo findet der statt?
In Leipzig.
Und was genau passiert für alle Leute, die noch nie vom Chaos Communication Kongress gehört haben?
Da passieren so viele Dinge, dass man es eigentlich nicht in einen Satz reinbekommt. Aber es ist so die eher größte, komplett ehrenamtlich organisierte Hacker-Veranstaltung Europas mindestens. Der, wie neben so einem offiziellen Vortragsprogramm mit 160 Vorträgen zu allen möglichen spannenden Themen. Auf den großen Bühnen gibt es viele kleine Bühnen, wo Erfahrungen ausgetauscht werden, technische Informationen, politische, wissenschaftliche Informationen auf dieses Jahr auch Einsteigerniveau erklärt werden. Es gibt große Bereiche, in denen sich die 16.000...
Halt! Ja, Einsteigerniveau. Heißt das zu jedem Vortrag gibt es einen Einsteigervortrag? Oder gibt es so eine Extra- oder gibt es so Marke an den Vorträgen? Hier kann man noch hingehen, wenn man keine Ahnung hat.
Es gibt Marke an den Vorträgen, und die Teams, die dieses Programm kureatiert haben, die haben ein Augenmerk darauf gelegt, möglichst, wie nennen die, Foundations, also die Grundlagen von bestimmten Bereichen, die gerade spannend sind, und wo sich vielleicht einige nicht ran getraut haben, weil sie denken, ey, großer Hacker-Kongress, das verstehe ich doch eh alles nicht, geben wir uns dieses Jahr Mühe, dass zum Teil Experten im Feld einfach unterhaltsam und auf Einsteigerlevel einen Blick oder einen Start in das Thema geben.
Auch nicht nur bei den neuen Themen, sondern auch bei ganz fundamentalen Themen. Wie sollte jeder wissen?
Es ist für jeden was dabei. Es gibt sogar Löten für Kinder. Jeder ist willkommen und kann kommen. Aber wenn ihr kein Ticket bekommen habt, könnt ihr euch die Vorträge auch online angucken. Und auch die Vorträge der letzten Jahre. Im Gegensatz, da ist es mal anders als so einige, wir wollen jetzt keine Namen nennen, große Wissenschaftsverlage, die das anders angucken.
Also ja, wir geben uns viel Mühe, das Live zu streamen und am Ende immer noch in unserer digitalen Bibliothek für alle zur Verfügung zu halten.
Okay, also es gibt keine Tickets mehr im offiziellen Vorverkauf.
Haus verkauft leider.
Also aus eigener Erfahrung, so wie in der Nähe der Kongress, desto öfter fragen auf Twitter mal Leute, ich kann doch nicht, ich will noch jemand. Aber ich habe gesagt, löten für Kinder. Aber ich bin kein Kinder, aber ich kann trotzdem nicht löten. Darf ich trotzdem?
Ja klar.
Es gibt noch einen ganzen Tag dediziert, heißt Junghackertag, wo auch noch...
Warte mal, Datum, wann ist der?
27. bis 30. inklusive.
27. 27. bis 30.
Ich glaub, traditionelleren Tag.
Wir gehen nur vorbereitet in die Sendung.
Jetzt lehne ich mich nicht aus dem Fenster. Danny Moog guckt gerade nach. Aber mir ist wichtig, dass der Kongress nicht nur das ist, was auf den Bühnen passiert, auf den offiziellen und was irgendwie auch gestreamt wird in die Republik, sondern es viele kleine Inseln, wo sich Leute zusammenfinden, auch selbst organisiert, heißen Assemblies, die einfach bestimmte Themenbereiche dann beackern, an denen sie ganz interessiert sind und wo sie auch Gäste willkommen, heißen an ihren Tischen. Weil wir davon ausgehen, dass eigentlich alle, die da mitmachen, sind Teilnehmer auf der Veranstaltung und sind dann eben immer in den kleinen Inseln der Kompetenz und des Erfahrungsaustauschs auch willkommen.
Um das zu klären. Der Jungenhackertag ist am zweiten Kongrestag, das ist der 28. Dezember. Und die Modalitäten, man kann dieses Ticket erwerben, kriegt ein Jugendlicher unter 18 Jahre oder eine Begleitperson eintritt.
An dem Tag.
An dem Tag, genau. Also, sowohl der Jungenhacker als auch die Begleitperson benötigen ein solches Ticket.
Und an dem Tag gibt es dann auch extra Programme.
An dem Tag sind die meisten Assemblies, haben dann etwas zurechtgelegt. Nachwuchshacker, die müssen nicht unbedingt mal alle noch ganz jung sein. Da vonlöten lernen über...
Ich wollte gerade sagen, was ist denn ein Jungenhacker für euch?
Jeder unter 18 erst mal.
Ja, gut gesagt.
Genau, und die sollen sich wenden an junghackertag.de Wenn ihr kein Ticket mehr gekriegt habt, dann schnappt euch jemanden unter 18.
Das ist clever, das ist sehr clever.
Das ist ein Hack.
Für Nachwuchssorgen, ne? Sehr, sehr gut.
Wird ein bisschen knapp mit Nachwuchsproduzieren jetzt.
Nein, ich meine Nachwuchs im Sinne von ihr sorgt dafür, dass junge Menschen auf den Kongress kommen.
Genau.
Über den Daumen gepaart?
Über den Daumen, so 15.000 bis 17.000. Und was jedes Mal wie stolz macht, ist, dass es eine Schar von Freiwilligen gibt, die dann auf der Veranstaltung selber noch Schichten fahren, wo sie da wirklich Arbeit erledigen über einen längeren Zeitraum. Und obwohl sie Eintritt bezahlen, dort dann Flaschen sammeln, die Tür bewachen, Videoaufzeichnungen mitmachen.
Du verkaufst das falsch. Indem man Engel, so nennt man das, erlebt man den Kongress nämlich erst richtig, nämlich backstage. Und deswegen darf man sich diese Gelegenheit nicht entgehen lassen.
Gleich anmelden, engelsystem.de.
Was sollte man noch vorher gemacht haben, wenn man jetzt dahin kommt?
Virenschutz installieren?
Und zwar physisch und auf seinem Rechner. Das heißt, es gibt... Da bei so vielen Menschen auf engsten Raumen gibt es da so eine Herdenimmunität, die die Teilnehmer mitbringen sollten, um bestimmte Krankheiten da nicht zum Ausbruch kommen zu lassen. Das heißt, eine Grippeschutzimpfung ist, glaube ich, zu empfehlen. Weil es gibt da diese sprichwörtliche Kongressseuche schon seit 20 Jahren.
Das ist ein Biohazard-Symbol.
Anfang Januar dann noch plattliegt und deswegen... Hände waschen, genau.
Aber das ist ja... Wo wir gerade bei Neuling sind, da ist ja die große Angst. Kann ich da mal ein neuartiges Rundfunkempfangsgerät mitnehmen oder wird mir das unter dem Arsch weggehackt?
Du kannst dein neuartiges Rundfunkempfangsgerät mitnehmen. Da sind ja zwar Leute mit Kompetenz, aber auch Leute, die Empathie mitbringen anderen Menschen gegenüber. Die machen eben nicht mal die Hardware von allen interessierten Teilnehmern dieser Veranstaltung kaputt.
Trotzdem, was meinst du mit Virenschutz auf der Maschine installieren? Also man sollte schon...
Sollte man eh immer update deine Backups.
Genau, Backup machen vor dem Kongress. Das ist eine große Veranstaltung, da sind ganz viele Leute unterwegs. Und vielleicht, also manchmal, ich hab das auch erlebt, macht es so viel Spaß, dass man den Rechner einfach mal stehen lässt und dann ist der weg.
Ja, aber meistens ist die Erfahrung, dass du ihn wieder hast und zwar aufgeladen. Ernsthaft, gibt es Leute, die davon berichtet haben? Nicht nur einstellig Fälle.
Okay, ihr habt ja schon vermutlich einer, zwei, drei vielleicht alle schon mal ins Programm geguckt. Also das steht ja noch nicht fest, was wann kommt, aber die Inhalte sind ja schon da. Gibt es so ein Thema irgendwie, wo ihr seid, dieses Jahr ist besonders viel davon da oder habt ihr irgendwas gesehen, wo ihr denkt, das möchte ich auf jeden Fall sehen, das sollte man sich schon mal merken?
Ich bin darauf gespannt auf die, jetzt kommen wir zu dem Sicherheitsproblem auch, der Spectre Meltdown, dass wir so viele Chips, also Computermaschinen haben, die von irgendwelchen Firmen gemacht sind, die Probleme haben, ein Gegengewicht dazu ist, dass wir lernen, wie diese Maschinen hergestellt werden und dass wir lernen, das selber zu machen. Das finde ich sehr spannend und ziemlich wichtig.
Inwiefern meinst du das? Selber Router bauen?
Das können wir schon, würde ich sogar behaupten. Aber jetzt geht es mir um Halbleiter tatsächlich.
Also tatsächlich die Bauteile selber bauen zu Hause?
Die Bauteile selber. Ja, haben auch Leute in der Küche gemacht tatsächlich, aber da braucht man so einen Ofen mit 1000 Grad und das ist nicht ganz trivial.
Aber in so einem Chaos Computer Club zum Beispiel?
Würde es vielleicht gehen, ja, oder wenigstens lernen, wie die Industrie das macht und dass wir das auch anfangen zu machen unter uns. Und dass wir dass wir dieselben Dienstleister auch benutzen können, wie die Industriehersteller. Und das finde ich persönlich sehr spannend.
Okay, wird es auch Unterhaltungsprogramm geben?
Es gibt einen Poetry Slam mit Hacker-Einschlag, der hoffentlich wohl vorbereitet wird.
So wie die Sendung?
Das Motto der Veranstaltung ist Refreshing Memories.
Warum?
Ist schön mehrdeutig, hat irgendwie so Konnotationen von wirklich physisch. Dein Speicher in deinem Rechner muss refreshed werden, immer regelmäßig, damit die Information da drin nicht verloren geht. Also die Grundsätze, wie Ramm funktioniert, ist Flip-Flops, die sich immer wieder neu durchdrehen. Aber auch ist halt eine Kulturtechnik, immer wieder seine Erinnerungen aufzufrischen in bestimmte Dinge, die vor 20, 50, 60, 100 Jahren passiert sind, nicht alle noch mal neu durchleben zu müssen. Und zuletzt ist ein Wortspiel von erfrischenden Erinnerungen, die da mit drinstecken, dass die Erinnerungen an die vergangenen Kongresse und an vielleicht schönere Zeiten, die aber wahrscheinlich eh alle scheiße waren, uns dazu bringen, überhaupt noch weiterzumachen mit dem ganzen Kram, die Welt zu verbessern.
Wünsche ich dabei viel Spaß, also sowohl beim Weltverbessern als auch beim Chaos-Communication-Kongress Ende des Jahres. Das war's für dieses Jahr vom Chaosradio im Blue Moon. Vielen Dank euch. Ich weiß jetzt irgendwie alles ist kaputt, aber man soll trotzdem nicht die Hoffnung aufgeben und es gibt noch ein paar schöne Spielzeuge. Liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, merkt euch auf jeden Fall den 28. Januar. Das wird eine ganz besondere Ausgabe des Chaosradios. Streckt euch schon mal ein, vielleicht könnt ihr sogar vorbeikommen. Also haltet euch da mal schon frei. Das war's für heute, das war's für 2018. Mein Name ist Markus Richter. Ich habe eine wichtige Nachricht für euch. Lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups.